real Dori Kosh direct
entry
out okay Mike grab both of my hands in
this situation I'm going to go straight
towards Mike similar to how I might do a
a tin chagi driving one hand high and
one hand low as I do this my my back leg
is going to step in between Mike's feet
and that hand is going to drive low so
I'm drive as far down as I can at the
same time my outside hand is going to go
high up this hand is also going to reach
in and grab his wrist as I make that
movement so I come in in one movement
like this from here I've now lowered
myself and my lower back set up right to
take Mike's weight I simply rock over
and take them up now notice there's no
strain on my back here Mike's right
across my hips it's an easy turn from
here to let Mike
down one more time at
speed right
a rori Kosh direct
entry